[Music]
stanford university
today's session is on the future of
medicine we have um three speakers with
us today so david rue who was former
chief medical officer at samsung and
currently chief medical officer at
microsoft christina farr who's a health
tech lead and investor at omer's
ventures and she was also previously a
health and tech reporter at cnbc along
with fast company and reuters news and
then of course our very own steve chan
from stanford school of medicine who is
also at the va health and paul auto so
some of the topics that we'll be
covering today given that we're in the
middle of a pandemic coven 19 and just
general topics around vaccine passports
infectious diseases and pandemics along
with changes in technology due to covid
such as telehealth and mental health
some topics around ai and unstructured
data sources a little bit around mixed
reality and virtual reality given the
interest around venture capital and
investment opportunities we'll also
cover that component for a little bit as
well as the important topic of health
equity as well and just issues of health
disparity and access to health care i'll
go ahead and start off with a few
questions targeting infectious diseases
and pandemics and i know david this is
also your background as well prior um to
being at samsung and microsoft and your
specialty area and maybe we can start
off with you in terms of vaccine
passports being a hot topic any thoughts
you might have in terms of how can and
should we develop vaccine passports or
should we not think about doing that and
also as it relates to data privacy and
information security as well
yeah i think the first thing to
recognize is that the discussion is
really more focused on health
credentials and allowing consumers and
individuals to be able to gain access to
those records on a device of their
choice or a technology of their choice
and that's a topic that has been
long-standing an initiative that many
organizations have been working towards
it just so happens that the focus right
now is on the vaccinations but
ultimately it will also include test
results and it will probably need to
also include genomic variants etc so i
think we're going to start seeing
a greater emphasis on the the broader
look of what type of data do need does
need to be captured and so the first
aspect of any type of mechanism where
one would use this in a means to provide
some kind of entry or
admission into a certain area would
involve the ability for us to issue that
type of a certificate what we have been
seeing and actually promoting is the
issuance using a common standard
and that standard being a smart on fire
standard that allows us to be able to
have greater interoperability so that
different systems can all communicate
with each other so if you were to
receive the the vaccine in any part of
the world with any electronic health
record the goal is that you only need to
have one type of credential and that
would be understood and readable
throughout so that has been a big area
of universal consensus that i think most
people would agree is good thing in fact
there's an entire initiative that
microsoft as well as a variety of other
organizations including some of the
leading electronic health record vendors
like epic and cerner are part of it's
called the vaccine credentials
initiative and that
is really actively promoting the use of
the smart on fire standard the second
piece though is where it often times
gets a bit more complicated because
there's now a sort of a transactional
piece where you you'll show the
credential and and this software
application uh or
program will actually
determine whether or not this meets the
criteria for predefined criteria for
some kind of entry and that's where
you're starting to see a lot more of
these companies come up that are popping
that are starting to develop uh what
they've referred to or some people refer
to as passports but again really it is
what it is just a verification of the
credentials against the standard and
then how it's used will be dictated by
policy it could be governments it could
be
airlines it could be a variety of other
organizations in fact we work very
closely with many of the governments
across the the globe and i was talking
to the health administers within the
country of israel and they've been one
of the organizations that are currently
using this type of technology and what
they're doing is they're enabling this
to enable entry
and exit out of the country and into
certain facilities but what's
interesting about their their approach
is it's not just vaccination but it's
also labs and so you so that this gets
to the whole point of there there's
probably a little bit more of an over
indexing on the vaccination piece you
still need lab results to
demonstrate that you haven't been
recently exposed and
so what we're seeing now is that there
are certain
organizations that are starting to adopt
this there's been a lot of discussion in
the eu the european union whether or not
they will also adopt these type of
standards and of course here in the
united states there's been active
discussions around that and so i think
what you'll start seeing is more and
more people will start recognizing that
this could
in many ways just facilitate the entry
or enable greater confidence the default
is you just these organizations are
still going to to require the
documentation it's just going to be a
lot more burdensome for individuals to
be able to go and carry that paper
document which could be get crumpled up
or lost in your pocket or wherever so i
i would envision that if and when we see
policies being developed around this
people will embrace the digital version
of this because it'll be so much easier
and faster and more efficient
i'm glad that you mentioned the issue of
interoperability of health records since
it's a topic that jason from our class
was also interested in touching upon a
little bit and really the idea that you
use the records to its fullest
potentials the systems do need exchange
data with one another um question for
steven christina is why is this so
difficult it seems to be an issue that
we've talked upon constantly for the
last few years is it really technical
limitations or limitations on standards
or cost constraints or why is this such
a big issue for just getting these
health records to talk to one another in
exchange data
so this is one of the big topics i was
covering in my reporting career going
back to
even right after the the affordable care
act when we got some reforms called high
tech that were supposed to usher us into
this era of interoperability
and unfortunately while
at the time i think a lot of work was
done to get doctors to move from
paper-based systems to
more digital ones and that was a big
accomplishment we just we didn't
actually overcome this hurdle of moving
towards interoperability of you know
actually having this medical information
be freely shared and there's lots of
reasons for that but i think on the
rather cynically and i'll just say it
like the industry just didn't want to
adopt these standards it wasn't in the
financial interest of the healthcare
system at the time and so
what you ended up seeing is the
government trying to
pass all these rules to get kind of
companies specifically the vendors to
open up in the health systems to embrace
it what you ended up seeing is they
would meet the requirement technically
but not the spirit of the law and if you
had to share a certain amount of data
they would do be able to do that once
and then never again and it was just all
kind of things like that that you
started to see in response and so we
didn't really solve the problem and and
we're still trying to solve it and
there's been a lot of movement with 21st
century cures i think has been great and
we're starting to see more of an api
based approach and now i think the big
hope is that the patient or the consumer
will rise up and say this is my
information these are my records these
are my labs this is my test results and
i should have access to this and we are
seeing this more and more within kind of
patient groups and i think
that is going to be where we see change
it's going to be driven by the patient
and less from kind of the system itself
so do you want to touch upon one of the
biggest changes that has happened due to
coven 19 which is telehealth and how did
telehealth evolve during this pandemic
and also what hurdles do we still face
specifically on the regulatory side for
a major adoption of telehealth
i i can jump in honestly this is
something that we've seen
pretty widespread adoption of telehealth
during the pandemic there have been
numbers 220 or 200 fold increase in
telehealth visits there's a significant
amount of adoption barriers that have
been removed many people who were afraid
or even unwilling to try it before i
have been doing it and so we've seen
some significant strides but at the same
time we've also exposed several
of the deficiencies of relying on these
technologies first and foremost lack of
broadband access people not with lack of
digital literacy and just
uncomfortableness of doing it there's a
greater preference in many cases to just
simply go within person so i feel like
tremendous strides have been made in
terms of adoption and utilization that
there's still work to be done and then
the other element is the funding or the
the reimbursement and what we saw was an
opportunity for
organizations to get paid for basically
the services that are provided through
telehealth but the challenge and the big
question is whether or not those uh will
continue post-pandemic
i think i agree with all of that and i
would add that
there's been a lot of hype during this
pandemic about telemedicine and a lot of
folks especially in the venture
community are really excited about it i
think there's also a growing recognition
that it is just one tool and a toolkit
and there's lots of other ways in which
we can engage with patients including
home visits and we don't even need in
some cases video visits it could be as
simple as a landline or even an sms
there's lots of ways that i think we can
think about
interacting between kind of doctors and
patients or providers and patients and
so
as we look to the future i think there's
a sort of growing recognition that we
need to use all of these and it should
be the patient's preference that that
drives it in some cases that a video
visit might make a lot of sense and in
others maybe that patient does need to
come in and we need to accept that
there's a whole range of tools here that
we can be deploying and so that's how i
think about telemedicine is just it's a
technology which is a vehicle for
delivering care versus the care itself
you would love to hear any additional
thoughts you might have on this topic
and also in general given your focus on
mental health what are some of the
changes that we have seen and new
innovations we've seen due to covid and
do you think that we can truly replace
psychotherapists with a computer program
in the future
yeah i think that telehealth over the
past year has really opened up a lot of
opportunities really opened up a lot of
people provider of providers eyes
particularly in psychiatry
my specialty there have been
a lot of traditionalists and
old-fashioned thinking and leadership
positions
that have encouraged basically
face-to-face visits and essentially with
telehealth it's really shown that it's
like essential just for everyone's
protection and a lot of staff prefer it
too
and we've i can't speak for the veterans
affairs in this current capacity but i
know that it's been wonderful to recruit
and retain
talent for psychiatrists and other
providers who are otherwise
difficult to
recruit in say very expensive costs of
living areas
so i think that some of the hurdles that
we still have yet to face certainly with
the reimbursement that we've discussed
but also
not and also the certainly the
connectivity issues just imagine how
sometimes we have netflix buffering and
and low resolution videos but also for
mental health specifically
trying to
piece together all the parts of the
continuum of care and trying to see if
some of it can be done
without having a human involved or for
instance education component or having a
follow-up automated follow-up but i
think that there still will be
a place for human involvement because
there's going to be that attachment
where someone wants to talk with to talk
of a human but it just depends on which
how severe um your illness might be or
how much engagement you might have so i
think there's going to be a lot of
variety it's just opening up a lot of
different options for us
so i'd be remiss if we didn't touch upon
ai and david some of our earlier
conversations more broadly the topic of
unstructured data sources and
very hot techniques nowadays microsoft
buying uh nuance the speech recognition
firm for about 16 billion dollars and
curious on your thoughts in general
maybe you aren't able to speak about the
acquisition directly yet but the role of
voice user interfaces for healthcare and
how we should be thinking about
unstructured data sources like voice and
text
yeah if you take the broader context of
natural language processing and
understanding how we can take these
unstructured forms and provide some
structure and context to it i'll start
with voice voice has been an incredibly
powerful
opportunity for us to
understand if we can do voice to text
but then not just simply get it to text
but understand the contextual
understanding of the terms so once you
actually understand that you can then
organize it into a clinical note into
different formats and then integrating
it into the medical record and that
essentially is what microsoft in
collaboration and partnership with
nuance had done for actually for the
past couple of years we've been working
on this and then we launched a product
called dax or dragon ambient experience
which is essentially the ability to do
that in the setting of a clinical visit
we also attached that to microsoft teams
so this was available for virtual visits
and so this opportunity to be able to
apply this in the real world
was super exciting in fact we we have
more recent data that suggests or that
that shows that the amount of
documentation has actually decreased the
amount of time that doctors are spending
with patients by 50
and it's also increased the throughput
by about 30 percent so it's already
demonstrating significant value in in a
in a topic or an area that has just been
an incredible pain point for clinicians
the ability to remove that and not have
to have either the clinician do it or a
scribe do it it's just been an
incredibly powerful opportunity but
there's also another element to that
which is once you actually understand
the context of the terms and the words
that are being said we can actually
start doing real-time decision support
and start looking for opportunities to
improve quality safety regulatory
adherence or even prior authorizations
and so that's going to even further
enhance the value of how we can apply
this there's another element for natural
language processing where there's also
been significant advancements and that's
in the area of text analytics and some
of the things that we have been spending
time
trying to do is develop algorithms and
ai tools that will allow us to be able
to similarly understand the context of
what's being said so we can do smarter
types of searches and what i mean by
that is we can search through medical
literature like the full text and the
abstracts and look for
studies that have shown that a
particular
genotype with a particular cancer it has
a certain outcome with when given a
certain treatment that's the type of
stuff that would require clinicians to
find do these public searches and spend
hours reading the articles and trying to
sort it all out or rely on some kind of
a published meta-analysis but we have
the ability to do that type of
information searches real time and then
now imagine also being applied that
applying that to like progress notes and
text notes and things that come in that
completely unstructured
that have tremendous amount of
information so what we're now doing is
we're expanding the amount of available
data sources that we can to deeply
understand the individual and where they
are on their journey which is going to
help us to develop and refine some of
our predictive algorithms
christina i love your thoughts in terms
of what are some of the major obstacles
to implementing ai and machine learning
in healthcare is it is one of the
challenges for instance that we talked
about healthcare data being so difficult
to share in exchange and the fact that
it's so highly fragmented is that one of
the major obstacles or are there other
hurdles from the technical side or yeah
i think there's a lot there's a lot to
this on the investing front we often see
ai
slash medicine companies coming out of
israel and the reason for that is
because they have this incredible
healthcare system which is very capable
of pulling together medical information
quickly and they and there's a strong
willingness there to share it for the
purposes of kind of data analysis and ai
but the problem with that is in israel
you have a very specific population that
doesn't tend to include a lot of
minorities and we see some but not
enough where you could come up with a
data set that would be directly
applicable to
population say in the us and other parts
of the world and so i think we
weighed into this issue here of medical
bias which we see a lot and we see
because i think humans are fundamentally
biased we see it in the algorithms too
but then you also end up with issues
like we don't do enough medical research
to incorporate say women
and that also gets baked into these
algorithms and women may experience for
instance kind of heart attacks
differently than men and in those cases
what happens when the algorithm isn't
built to recognize those symptoms and
you end up with a bunch of kind of apps
that where a woman would type in her
symptoms and it wouldn't necessarily
direct her into the emergency room in
time so i think those are some of the
kind of ethical questions that that
we're facing and then there's also this
issue of just the medical
system that the physicians have have
been told time and time again over the
course of several decades that here is
this kind of ai breakthrough coming from
silicon valley that's going to
revolutionize the way that you you
practice and in many cases that's turned
out not to be true and it's been
part of a hype cycle and so now a lot of
the doctors that i talk to are quite
skeptical when they hear about a new ai
company and i think there's
a lot to prove here and companies like
microsoft are very aware of this and are
approaching with caution and i think
creating technologies that are starting
to impress doctors at least that's from
what i'm hearing but there have also
been cases like with ibm watson where it
was just i think if you followed that
whole saga it turned out not to meet the
the great promise that was being offered
so i think we just need to tread
carefully as entrepreneurs when we
approach kind of these providers with
these claims and and we have to be able
to back them up with evidence
i'm glad you're touching upon the topic
of health equity as well david i know
that you talked briefly about broadband
access
and would love to hear your thoughts
david in terms of how we find ways to
advance vaccine equity and how this in
general speaks to the broader issues of
health disparity that we have in our
system
yeah this is a really timely topic
obviously the big emphasis has been get
as many vaccines to in as many arms as
quickly as possible and that continues
to remain a primary goal but in the
process we are leaving behind the most
vulnerable the highest risk individuals
who will as we continue to open the
gates further to allow for more entry of
participants including younger kids are
going to get left behind and unless we
develop alternate pathways to enable
these individuals to be able to get the
vaccine and i think the current approach
that if you look at what we've done in
terms of providing vaccines availability
through retail clinics and through
community health centers gets us to that
last mile
but we may actually need to go to the
last inch and what i mean by that is
we're going to need another push because
we are we work with many organizations
across the country and i'll give you an
example lausd los angeles unified school
district they're one of our key
strategic partners we've been helping
them with the return to school effort
we've been enabling testing for the
students as well as the faculty which is
extended to the family members and now
at vaccinations what's happened is
within la
the community health centers are all
saying we've got all this vaccine and no
one's coming and think of that we talk
about how we're running out of vaccine
and we're so lit but in certain parts
we're finding that individuals are just
not going or not interested in going and
what we have to do is we have to
understand that there has to be more
than just simply providing access and
this ties into a deeper issue of who has
the long-standing trusted relationships
with those individuals and what we've
learned in talking with many of the
folks that
basically work in this space is that
it's not
kind of healthcare providers are
certainly on the list but it's not we're
not tapping into the full range of folks
that are out there and so i what we've
learned is not-for-profits schools
churches these are all organizations
that need to be engaged in this process
and so part of what we're now looking to
do is
form public-private partnerships that
allow for an opportunity to enable and
empower these organizations to be able
to deliver vaccines and other health
services into these underserved
communities and to do this in a way that
allows us to be able to go beyond
covered activities and potentially now
to health screenings and to health
maintenance it's an exciting opportunity
for us to be able to start rethinking
some of the models of care that allow us
to be able to deliver care more
equitably to these populations
steve i would love your thoughts on the
topic of health equity and specifically
are there investments in technology that
address minority mental health for
instance those with limited english
proficiency or those with difficult
ailments or diseases
i think that's an area of need certainly
limited english proficiency has
certainly relied very heavily on persons
within the community who understand the
nuances for the ways of immigration the
cultural history and certainly just the
language itself in
in some of the research and the projects
that we've been looking at with of
speech recognition
and lep patients there's not the there's
not a lot of activity it seems in this
area that's certainly one area for
instance can we get a
physician or a provider
who speaks that person's language and it
can be very a challenge right i think
that also with health equity certainly
not just the broadband access but we've
talked about how
in our last certainly our last class 5g
it would be nice to have like high
quality
streaming video so that we can see
as many of the nuances during a
mental status exam we call it to see
someone's motor activity to see how
someone's walking maybe even notice if
they have any any sort of contraband or
bottles and such in the back background
where they are living so i think that it
can be something that we could help with
better technology and certainly better
technology access i'd say a lot of the
folks i'm reaching out to only only are
able to really connect by phone and have
incredible challenges getting videos set
up
so there's a lot of work that can be
done to bridge certainly bridge the gap
one more thing i just realized too
is uh we actually have something called
a digital divide consult digital divide
referral where we have social workers
who reach out to
veterans
who are lacking in either the webcam or
the computer or even the wireless
connection and they'll give them a
wireless hotspot attached to an ipad or
combined with an ipad so that they can
do video visits and i think that's
helped quite a bit and why not why can't
we not roll that out to everybody so
that's there's a lot of work that
certainly can be done
so i know a topic that a lot of students
in the class wanted to cover was just
around investing in health care and
investment opportunities chrissy as the
investor on our panel what are some of
the verticals and trends that are
popular right now that you might be
looking at related to health tech and
related to that what are some areas that
have been overhyped as well yeah gr
these are great questions i'm fairly new
to the to the venture side i've been
around for enough time to get a good
sense of what my day job is going to be
like and so far at least it's been fab
so i'm happy to share some of the the
themes that we've identified because as
i was going into this new role i had a
list in my mind and nothing has really
changed since then so the definitely my
top priority at the moment is behavioral
health so i really appreciated hearing
some of steven's comments and i think
the reason that we want to do something
there is because it's it's really shown
us during the pandemic that this need
that we have to say i would call it a
crisis we have a crisis of mental health
in this country and we don't have
sufficient access to
providers there's so many people that
need help that can't get it even here in
the bay area anyone who's tried to
access a therapist in recent months i
know i have and i couldn't find anyone
who would take my insurance it was a
weeks-long process and eventually had to
give up and that's with insurance that's
with resources i i just it's hard to
even imagine what it's like for for
everyone else who isn't deeply embedded
in the healthcare system to begin with
so i think that's a big reason and then
the other issue that we're facing there
is just the fact that someone like
stephen a psychiatrist there's only 5
000 being graduated every single year
and more than that retiring
so if you look at where we're going to
be in the next 10 years it's an we're
going to be in a place where there's so
few providers that can treat just this
growing storm of patients that that need
care and so i think the sort of big
question on everyone's mind now is is
what can we do about that short of kind
of training a lot more psychiatrists and
mental health providers which i think we
absolutely need to do is there a way
that technology can play a role is there
some way in which we can make the
existing pool of providers able to
access more patients than before and so
that's the question that we're looking
into and
you know i personally would love to do
something for kids and teens in that
space because there's so little for
those groups and i think for college
students for high school students and
even younger there's a lot of data
showing that
with every year that passes there's more
and more people that are suffering from
anxiety and depression and numerous
other things that where they're just not
getting help so i think those are some
big things that i'm looking into now
another area that i think is really
underserved that i would love to make an
investment is in women's health and
having just had a baby i've seen you
know firsthand that there's just so much
that we need to do i'm
i've had i had the baby two months ago
i've had one medical visit since then
it's and that was because i have
insurance i only saw a doctor six weeks
postpartum and there's so much for those
who've had babies there's there's so
much that can happen in the first few
months that it's just shocking to me
that i've just been essentially just
dropped off at home and told to figure
it out and it isn't like that in other
countries we have one of the the highest
maternal mortality rates if not the
highest in in the developed world are
where the us is on par with latvia and
oman
so i think we have a lot of work to do
there as well and i'd love to it's
another area where i just i continue to
meet founders and see a lot of you know
really promising companies that are
looking to address some of these
problems there's a lot more but i'm
always there and happy to answer more
questions
david i would love your thoughts related
to that around mixed reality i know
microsoft hololens is a big project and
i bring it up because i think as
investors oftentimes what drives our
investment decisions is also what the
big players are doing and what's the
next 16 billion dollar acquisition that
you're going to make i would love to
hear from you in terms of how you're
thinking about using mixed reality for
improving healthcare and
i think microsoft has done a few things
around this already
i'll give you an example to show you the
potential opportunity with mixed reality
we showcased this at one of our recent
events it was a case study in which a
physician a surgeon in mount sinai was
helping a surgeon in uganda perform the
surgery and traditionally one thinks of
you know telemedicine and being able to
guide them but what was unique about
this was the surgeon in uganda while
looking through the hololens on the
surface of the the body
could see the surgeon in
sinai outline exactly where the incision
needed to be and they followed through
and he just basically followed along
it's almost as if you had the person
right there next to you showing you even
better because they're actually writing
on the patient in a virtual pen
this is an incredible opportunity for us
to start rethinking what's possible
relative to how we can use these newer
technologies and and there's a
significant amount of obviously consumer
use cases and other business use cases
for hololens but within healthcare one
of the great opportunities is how we can
transform medical education to scale
individual skills such as we talked
about stephen and his needing to scale
and clone stephen more of him but we we
also need to do that outside of the us
as well and get more healthcare
providers there are many folks that just
need basic skills and training around
doing procedures as well if you were
thinking about emergency procedures
chest tubes and in endotubial
intubations and things like that what we
can do is we can actually start
rethinking how we can train individuals
to more advanced procedures there's this
concept in healthcare it's called c1 do
one teach one i'm not sure if you've
heard of that but essentially what it
means is you have to see a whole bunch
of these types of procedures then you
have to do one with someone watching you
and guiding you and then eventually you
get to the point where you're a teacher
to do that it requires a lot of
people to see a lot of different things
and there's not just not enough people
to mentor and or
individuals to be able to try things on
you can actually go and accelerate that
dramatically with the use of these tools
so we could rethink how we can expand
and scale the medical training and then
the second piece is the the virtual care
element being able to actually do
procedures and do things that were
traditionally difficult to do in person
or virtually just like we can do
virtually in person and that's going to
create an opportunity when you combine
that with some of the advancements on
digital health and being able to get
more biometrics we literally can start
thinking about having a much more
intimate
encounter with either a clinician or a
patient with the data and the all the
aspects that make it something that
would be viewed as essential in terms of
coming in could now potentially be
something that we could think of as
being doing virtually so we're really
starting to push the boundaries of
what's possible because of the fact that
we've got new platforms new data sets
that are coming in and it's all driven
by ai and a large part of that is the
technology that underlies what we're
trying to build within our devices
i like that phrase c1 do want each one
um one of the questions and topics that
popped up from spencer in our class was
also just covering
thoughts that you guys might have in
terms of sectors that are promising for
investors that don't have meaningful
clinical expertise and then also a
fallout from one of alex's questions is
related to due diligence around health
tech startups and given a lot of times
the innovation novelty of these concepts
how do you actually conduct that
diligence so maybe christina we can
start with you and then steve would love
your thoughts as well
i can weigh in on the diligence question
given that we just completed a big
diligence process i'm happy to walk
everyone through that
so i think it might be somewhat
surprising to folks here because it
definitely was to me but a lot of the
the diligence that we end up producing
in the you know form of a investment
memo that you present to
the whole partnership is in our at least
for my fund it's a written document so
it's essentially telling a story and
that does include some numbers and
analysis of course but a lot of it is
driven by primary research so if you're
looking at a health tech startup states
in behavioral health you want to do a
clinical evaluation where you would
reach out to somebody like stephen and
get his um perspective on the company
and the board of space and you would
probably talk to a dozen or so folks
like that at least who could give you a
sense of whether or not this would
medically be viable and then you would
also want to diligence the team so find
out these founders good leaders what
kinds of things have they done
previously would they be able to build a
great team and depending on how kind of
late stage the investment is you might
start due diligence as well beyond the
founders your early executive team cfo
the cto what do people think of them who
know them intimately and then you would
look into the broader space to create a
market map where does this company fit
in if it's in mental health and you
would look at lots of other mental
health companies what kinds of exits
have they had what kind of funding have
they raised and then you think through
possible outcomes for the the company
that you're investing in would it be
sold to a microsoft in a most likely
scenario or is this a potential ipo and
why and and then you go to your your
partnership and you have to make a case
for this company
i think a lot of investors would say
that it's all about kind of financial
modeling and
i have no financial background at all
and i'm learning as i go but a lot of it
is storytelling you have to be able to
convince your team that this is a
company that we need to get behind and
that this is a company that can adapt
that can potentially pivot if needed
nobody could have been able to
financially model what would have
happened during the pandemic this past
year that would have been crazy and
impossible so a lot of it again is you
have to be able to do that storytelling
and i think that's why people with
humanity's backgrounds as well as stem
backgrounds can add a lot of value to to
a fund
besides reading uh david's linkedin
posts and reading chrissy's sub stack
newsletter the sources i get certainly
would be a lot of the industry reports
that even stanford's uh graduate school
of business and the stanford library has
access to that can be incredible source
to help figure out who are other players
in the market how big is the market
certainly and that's all accessible
through certainly the stanford library
subscription that you have
also having a wide network of colleagues
and a lot of folks who are here are
going to be superheroes and everyone has
a superpower which is just so incredible
and such a gift and so we each have our
own stories to tell and can learn from
each other but also in the future when
we're learning about the markets and the
industries too
and some of the things that i think
would be promising for the future
particularly within behavioral health
one of them certainly would be anxiety
conditions there are a lot of apps that
will address things like just you know
mild anxiety mild depression your sort
of bread and butter sort of psychiatric
cases but there's a whole
unaddressable set of folks who have just
been silently suffering quietly and not
thinking that anything could help them
so things like phobias for instance we
had talked about virtual reality earlier
the virtual reality mixed reality there
are some
companies who are working on things to
expose people we call it exposure
therapy where we expose someone to
something that's super stressful or
in varying doses of stress
and i think that could be that could
really relieve people some people
suffering that's one and then certainly
folks who are i was reached out by a
member of the press at 1.4 my take on a
video game therapist
and they were saying is this ethical for
someone to be reaching out to
video gamers on twitch and discord and
one of the things i've i realized is
that this for many gamers for instance
they just have they may have a lot of
things that they just have not been able
to address
and or reach out to or haven't
felt comfortable with i'm thinking of
things like video game addictions
behavioral addictions certainly the
addictions that i'm working on with
substance use disorder very stigmatized
there's a lot of fear around it when in
fact there's a lot of treatments that
are offered and then finally
things like eating disorders where a lot
of people are quietly suffering
certainly and a lot of the treatments
are expensive so eating disorders i know
there's some startups around that space
too so those are some of the things i'm
thinking about
i'd love to cover just a few other
topics that students have identified as
of interest so really for any of the
panelists to answer one of them is
stevie just touched upon this very
briefly just future technologies
impacting obesity in america such as
alternative meat or obesity pills i
would love if any of you have thoughts
on that
yeah i'll tell you i'll start first off
i think obesity is a major issue clearly
it's uh contributing to so many
conditions including even more mortality
due to clovid
one of the things that we have also
recognized is
it's a lot of it is not just necessarily
the technology that's going to drive
towards behavior change it's really
understanding what are some of the
behavioral motivating factors and
demotivating factors and i think when
you get into the mechanics of why do how
do you get people to live a healthier
life and how do you support them there
are a lot of things that i would say
healthcare needs to learn about from
behavioral scientists and behavioral
economists i'll give you a couple of
examples when you think about there was
a study that what they did is a very
simple one they just simply reconfigured
the shopping cart to have more room for
vegetables and fruits and vegetables and
it was one of those carts that actually
had it separated but by doing that
they
they didn't tell anyone that they had to
buy more vegetables or anything but it
when they started looking at the types
of vet the products that were being sold
it turned out that there was actually a
greater purchase of vegetables and
fruits than previously and these simple
things when you change the the structure
when you you downsize the size of your
your your your drinks to with those
super sized ones people tend to eat
what's on their plate and and drink
what's in their cup and when you like do
these little things they actually make a
big difference and and so these are the
types of things that i think we're
starting to realize we need to
incorporate into
our own systems and then from there we
can start applying other types of
reminders and coaches that can help
support us in that process because a lot
of this does require a team approach and
we have seen many of those coaching apps
as behavioral apps work very well but
it's oftentimes done in collaboration
with an ongoing assessment of how you're
doing and then other structural
interventions so i feel like
that's an opportunity for
individuals and organizations that that
deeply understand these type of
mechanics and i would also say that if
we can individualize and really
understand which type of interventions
work for which people when
that would be very helpful right now
clinicians we take a one-size-fits-all
approach and i'll tell you it doesn't
work very well it's usually i'm going to
give you a recommendation i'm going to
send you to a dietitian and i'm going to
cross my fingers that you're going to
actually eat better that doesn't work
and and so i think we have to find
better ways than what we currently do
so in terms of uh recommendation so a
question from the class is why has
personal health care not taken off is it
the barrier incentives technology or
other issues
i know okay maybe i'll start
i can tell you for
that we see generally speaking that a
lot of personalized health is geared
towards a very small subset of the
population the individuals that are
either quantified sufferers the worried
individuals that love the data and will
digest it
yes that it will maybe potentially help
those individuals but when you think
about mass adoption
those are not the folks who one you're
trying to target towards making improved
outcomes and two
that's not the majority and so what you
have to start thinking about is how do
you get to the folks who actually don't
want to put a wearable on who don't want
to use an app and who literally don't
want to be bothered
and then that's where we're going to
need to start thinking about programs as
opposed to apps programs that are
designed to enlist the support of family
members and other key support members
and empower them with the tools to be
able to do things and so rather than
relying on trying to change the behavior
on a particular individual people are
motivated more often by external factors
they'll care more about their child
or their mother or their parents than
they will about their own health and use
those elements in terms of trying to get
people to motivate to change their own
behaviors and if they're the ones who
are driving the behavior change allow
them to be empowered to be able to know
how things are going so i think that's
going to allow us to be able to shift
the focus away from the people who are
essentially the ones who are doing
fairly well to those who need it but
apply it in a way that is far more
comprehensive than an app
oh i'll add to that that i think one of
the issues that we saw at least when it
as it pertains to the wearables trend is
just there's all this focus on just how
do we create these devices and these
technologies for collecting
data but very little on what does this
data mean in context and then how do we
share it with the clinician in a way
that just doesn't become even more
overwhelming to them so you ended up
with a bunch of patients going in saying
look at what i've gathered for my fitbit
or my apple watch and the response from
not everybody many kind of clinicians is
okay and what am i supposed to do with
this i it doesn't necessarily mean much
to a patient's health and so i think we
need to focus a lot more on just
bringing this data into context and
making sure that when we collect data
that we're doing it with a specific kind
of clinical outcome or for a reason
beyond just the fact that we can collect
it
and i think a part of it too like what
chrissie's touched upon is how
comfortable with the healthcare worker
or healthcare provider be with the data
i know within behavioral health everyone
talks about the ninth question which is
of the phq-9 the phq-9 is a depression
screener the ninth question asks about
desire to harm yourself and
oftentimes we ask okay who's going to do
what with that data and so those are
just operational questions that can be
set up one of the
things one of the promising aspects i
think is if you're able to get the
provider
to
speak the lingo and understand how the
importance of the data then it could
unlock a lot of possibilities so for
instance our teams here they give us a
prescription pads with apps on the
prescription pads for the va
and i love that example because it's
something that's very tangible that a
lot of clinicians understand
we also have this amazing team that
actually will guide people to use an app
and i've
worked with this great researcher they
would actually onboard somebody and
guide them on the app and the app will
actually
help people cut down on drinking and
it's i've seen it happen if that but
that's if the provider is engaged
you know spencer had a comment just a
follow-up on the idea of future
technologies impacting obesity in
america and how different manufacturing
technologies are being applied to create
healthier food products
i'll say that in general these are all
exciting opportunities to start thinking
about ways that we can
reduce the amount of
cholesterol and fat and other types of
maybe harmful substances and and
substitute it with others there's also
this other process of like how much does
it actually cost
to make it and so i'm always uh
curious in terms of are we
adding more or less carbon to the
environment are we helping is there a
give and a get and so part of this is i
think we'll learn more and we'll find
ways to make things better but in the
effort in the rush to try to like make
something that is extremely
healthy if we end up
kind of causing harm in other ways it
may not necessarily be the best thing
overall so i i always personally just
have questions about that but i do agree
that there's some really exciting things
that can be done and i look forward to
finding ways that we can modify some of
the things that we have today in
particular try to reduce the amount of
polyunsaturated fats and ways that we
can
eat healthier and motivate people to do
things and put less sugar in if there's
ways that we can do that in a way that's
motivating and and it allows us to be
able to do this in a way that's
economically feasible for mass
production then that's terrific what
i've just generally found is that we
already we know what is healthy it's
fruits and vegetables and
if we can try to just
have not so much of an imbalance of what
we have and try to do eat healthy
exercise and and sleep well and and
reduce stressors and things like that
that along with along with social
connections will lead to long longevity
and i feel like we don't do what we know
already works we we're looking for
another solution sometimes
yeah i think those are all those are
fantastic points and i'm i would love to
do something in the kind of alternative
protein space i'm very plant-based
myself and i think it would be great to
scale up some of these companies that
it's not an area that we've focused on a
ton but just i've just heard through
a lot of reporting and and some research
on this topic that
some of the bottlenecks are just around
finding these these protein sources and
a lot of it is key protein and there's
been some challenges with that and then
also finding ways to scale um to meet
demand and i've sort i've seen
impossible foods and other companies say
that they want to completely replace
animal agriculture in the next several
decades but
projections outside of these companies
suggest that it will be more like five
or six percent of us is completely
replacing what we have so we we have
somebody at our fund that's focused on
climate change and he's looking at
agricult animal agriculture and i know
has sort of come around to
sustainable farming versus just looking
at alternative meat sources as a way to
tackle this because they also think that
for those who do cheese to to eat meat
that we
we also need to be focusing on better
approaches than the system that we have
right now which is
both terrible um for the animals but
also for for human health as well
another topic that steve all handed over
to you is the potential integration of
other health areas into primary care
such as dentistry and dietitians sure
some of the things
what you know i think some of the
questions had been relating to fitness
and nutrition and
and i know that amongst our team members
it's one area where
it's not part of the standard curriculum
for medical education or healthcare
education really and and so there's a
real opportunity in terms of if you're
trying to find a sort of industry or set
of products
that have a lower barrier of entry to
market it's not as regulated as say
medical biomedical devices or medical
pharmaceuticals
and
one one potential
avenue would be when you we had talked
about obesity earlier on for instance if
there's some way to tie in obesity
medicine with education or some meal
planning around diets and food that
could potentially be one business
opportunity and certainly fitness we've
seen
how peloton is just expanding to
different areas with the treadmill
products and we've had a lot of at-home
fitness products too
throughout the pandemic but those are
some of the areas i'd think about
expanding towards
so final question for all the panelists
what technology infrastructure
investment do you think is necessary to
better manage the next pandemic outbreak
and david why don't we start with you
so i think first and foremost we
recognize that the current public health
infrastructure is not set up to handle
pandemics
we've been looking at four areas where
we think will be critical if we are to
rebuild and continue to augment our
current capabilities the first is around
testing uh and really looking at how we
can create a survey network of different
test centers that do active surveillance
of individuals that are asymptomatic as
well as symptomatic largely what we have
today is pockets of testing that
sometimes get brought in and centralized
and sometimes they get thrown away
a lot of these data are
not
basically used because there isn't a
central process to bring it all together
if we look at models that south africa
has done in the uk where they've been
able to identify the variants but
they've been able to do it because they
have a very nice structure where the
genomic testing labs are associated with
the lab testing their facilities are
spread throughout the country that all
the tests are centralized this is a
critical infrastructure build that needs
to be put in place the second piece is
around
the whole element of accelerated r d and
enhanced manufacturing this is
everything from
ai to enable a greater sharing or
interoperability to enable greater
sharing of information large data sets
being brought in so that we can crunch
them and better analyze tremendous
amount of effort that's already been
applied in the pharma life sciences
space that will allow us to be able to
understand what needs to be done but
once you've actually got these that have
been tested we saw this firsthand mass
production and rapid delivery those type
of systems need to be available and to
do that
effectively we have to understand the
supply chain routes and where those
limitations are and so that's a critical
piece that needs to be understood and
brought in the third is around the
vaccinations and really we have seen
with the pandemic it's not just about a
one-time
get the vaccines and hopefully just make
it available we actually have to have an
active effort to vaccinate as many
people as possible as quickly as
possible in a prioritized manner and
then potentially booster shots and so
now what we're looking at is following
through this exact same cycle this
process has to have infrastructure that
will allow us to be able to support this
and then again back to the earlier point
if we don't hit those pockets of
unvaccinated high risk we're going to
run into the same problems that we run
into again with uh surges so that's a
huge area and then the last piece uh
which we have been spending a lot of
time is around this whole concept of
credentials and being able to understand
what can you do with certain tests and
what activities can you open up safely
and how do you closely monitor tying
back into the active testing and looking
at how we can be more proactive and so
all of this is tied together it's it
really does need to be an integrated
network where a lot of this data is
captured and provided and ultimately
this is the got to be the blueprint for
how within the states and within the
globe we start addressing both the
current and future pandemics
christina additional thoughts on that
um i think david covered some of the the
big points and a lot of the things that
i would have said so i'll add that i
think what really stood out to me during
this pandemic is just
some of our issues around health and
science communication
so when i was at cnbc a story that i did
that that went viral which was extremely
surprising to me because it was it
seemed like a kind of a nerdy topic but
it was about
why it's okay for scientists to change
their minds when faced with new evidence
and i use the example of
of masks because through at the
beginning of the pandemic there was just
not as much clarity on whether
people should be wearing these masks i
think the fear was that we would not
have enough and that would be and that
we needed to preserve masks for our
medical professionals and so eventually
with more data and more studies all of
this thinking evolved and in the end a
lot of public health groups came around
to the idea that everybody should be
wearing a mask and we understood the
mechanism of how the virus spreads a lot
better but the public
didn't quite like a lot of people in the
public saw that as
as some somehow a sign that the
scientists didn't know what they were
talking about that they were
inconsistent think about how you when
you hear a politician change their mind
you think that you often think that this
politician
is just moving with the trends and so
the same thing was suggested about the
scientific community and and this was
used as evidence that perhaps it's not
the right thing to wear a mask and so i
wrote a story just saying
scientists change their minds and in
fact when a scientist holds their hand
up and says
you guys i'm evolving my thinking
there's been some new data that's
actually a good thing in the community
you would be praised for doing that
and and i think it's just like simple
concepts like this that have to be
explained again and again because it may
be obvious to the scientific community
but it's not obvious to everyone else
and it can lead to
trust breakdowns and it can lead to lots
of inconsistencies in terms of the
public health recommendations and who's
following them and not following them
and i think with this pandemic it really
exposed for me that we have some big
gaps here that we need to think about
how to fill
thanks for sharing that example
steve final thoughts
for pandemic preparedness i think about
the high rates of stress and anxiety and
certainly substance use disorders and
addictions that have skyrocketed since
and it makes me think about how
certainly for the next pandemic if we
were able to make our technologies
allow give us more opportunities for
wellness and more opportunities for
positivity instead of the doom scrolling
that we've heard about
throughout covet 19 i think about
how there are so many different in
do not disturb settings and a lot of
things that are hard to access on a
typical smartphone unless you really
know what to look for i actually myself
noticed too that to speak about david
david's technologies microsoft has
actually met
employees where they're at with
microsoft viva and i actually i myself
have gotten like a lot of analytics
about wellness and like how many emails
i've been sending out and how much of my
time has been
dedicated to meetings versus thinking
time so if we had more things like that
i think that could really help us build
resilience for the next time we have to
face a major catastrophe or disaster so
that when we can power through